let's bring in CBS News Chief Washington
correspondent Major G joins us now major
good morning the president presents
himself as a major billionaire business
success but this report in the times
suggests he's been claiming business
losses so significant that in many years
he's paid zero federal income tax how
does he respond tonight well first of
all with the classic response it's all
fake news now the president will have a
golden opportunity to prove its fake
news if in fact it is by releasing his
tax documents don't expect that to
happen it might even be a rejoiner from
former Vice President Joe Biden go ahead
release the taxes prove the New York
Times is wrong Mr President the other
thing the president will say is look
this often looks so coordinated how does
this happen how does the times get all
this information released just before
the debate Trump supporters will hear
that and think there is something
suspicious and as Paula indicated the
president will do whatever he can to
redirect this line of questioning away
from him and toward Hunter Biden former
Vice President Biden's son alleging some
kind of corruption even though a senate
report drafted by Republicans didn't
find anything legally corrupt in Hunter
Biden's conduct but major this tax
report would seem to cut directly at the
foundation of the president's brand will
it have an impact on his base for base
supporters this will be difficult though
not probably the kind of thing to
dislodge them for a couple of reasons
one is they don't take their cues from
the investigative reporting team of the
New York Times first of all then there's
that whole coordination thing they'll be
troubled about but it does create
problems for them with this great theme
that I've talked to Trump supporters
about for the better part of four years
this President sacrificed a great life
and fantastic success to save our
country well if he wasn't that
successful and in fact he was using
mountains and mountains of continuous
losses to pay no federal taxes how does
that fit with that underlying theme for
those who peer deeply into that it will
be problematic but they've got to peer
deeply into it first major uh house
Speaker nany Pelosi says what's most
worrying in the New York Times report is
the hundreds of millions of dollars the
president owns to people unknown
entities unknown she calls it a national
security issue is that a legitimate
concern it's an assertion from a very
partisan figure in American politics but
it's not out of bounds we've never had a
president with this many business
connections this much debt and this much
ongoing operations that inal indeed deal
with people who who Lobby the government
as lobbyist here in this country use
Trump hotels and the like or foreign
governments who also do the same we've
never seen these kind of entanglements
the president will probably say tonight
if that comes up everyone knew about
that in 2016 I was elected anyway well
did we know everything we know now the
answer to that is no And for those
voters still undecided this could push
them into a category of uncomfortability
which would be problematic for this
President all right major I will leave
people with a lesson that you uh repeat
annually which is pundits will say
somebody won tonight but the voters
ultimately will decide they will have
their say indeed that's right that is
that a question or just you going to
take it away that was a that was a
wrapping it up St okay got it
wrap away Tony wrap away we got to go
it's the a block but we'll talk to you
later thank you major come back soon our
Prime Time coverage of the first
presidential debate starts tonight at
900 p.m. Eastern 600 p.m. Pacific right
here on CBS